[Music]
in double-treble news that with Chavo
Chavo Chavo submitted by Gio's hair
looks awesome oh thanks it's a bonny
it's okay
two brothers have been arrested for
allegedly stockpiling explosives in
there NYC apartment why is it like a
terrorist powers it like two dumb
brothers brothers having fun well it
seems like they're planning some [ __ ]
panel diesel shade of shedding yes I've
always in New York I wouldn't keep on
wanting you hurt people man like why why
can't you just be a normal teen brother
and just like blow up [ __ ] because
you're curious
yeah we're just hurt individuals well
these aren't teens 27-year oh [ __ ] mmm
and yeah so these guys even if I'm 50 I
want to blow [ __ ] up never get bored of
blowing [ __ ] up what was the last time
you blew something up
not in a long time but I think I'm uh
but I always want to blow [ __ ] up I
start the desire like what's your it
could be dynamite fireworks just
anything that just goes ball I will say
this I really really enjoy lighting
things on fire yeah me too I think
that's why I even like guns cuz it's
like each it's a technically to
miniature explosion and it just so
happens to shoot in a certain direction
all weekend I was on fire duty I spent I
spent three hours just building a fire
and keeping it going every night you
were like so excited I loved I could
just do it for a long it's therapeutic
yeah she go on Survivor
maybe after I learned how to survive
there's only one way to learn dude you
just can't use the lighter
I don't know how to do that Bart knows
how okay I like the to rock oh that yeah
that's not a do that you have to get
really thin thin shavings of some type
of tinder yeah that's the only way it'll
catch tinder the rock method is [ __ ]
hard the only kind of tinder I know is
the one that app were you just watching
of survivor and then you think you know
everything and then you feel like you
could be come back
you know what's the cheapest easiest
tinder way oh after you're done dry
drying or clothes you know that filter
with all that like
all right there huh if you take that put
that and Ziploc back when you go camping
that is like the easiest tenant I'm not
throwing those away now thank you very
much I'm actually going camping in
where's the invite oh you're the last
person I'm trying to plan I know I like
legit camping though I could be any type
of campaign please we always say we go
camping every [ __ ] year where are you
going careful if because Muriel hasn't
been the Joshua tree before Josh with
cheese she's gonna go together just you
we all want to go - I know I never been
there you know that I just said it's a
couple page let's all go without David
you know the kind of camping I like I'm
telling what yeah guys I like cabin
renting Big Bear cabins are pretty cool
yeah you know what I want a cabin that's
pretty nice has a hot tub and all these
things you but there's a fire pit
you know we're gonna do the fire pit
thing and there we go back home and you
know if you go camping I'm gonna be
cooking you're not going camping I'm
gonna cook is that big-ass bowl of my
poo that you get okay but you're not no
I don't bail on those things I just say
I don't know gonna go the thing that I
don't like is setting up a tent and
putting it down so maybe I'll just get a
higher advice like that part though you
could set up my tent
I don't oh my god shut up part but I
like waking up like when you wake up in
a sleeping bag and it's like just crisp
air around ya
I want to sleep outside Steve hates
camping and we've never gone camping
yeah cuz he likes to shower why I do
that too though even if I'm roughing it
I'll still have like a bottle not like
me yup me also have a bottle of water
and I'm still doing my little field
shower yeah like when I was in the
military everyone made fun of me but I
was fresh sheets him because he won't go
can because we just get that that that
water canteen you know the ones that you
put into the water upside down yeah you
just bring a couple of those and that's
specifically designated for washing
yourself and then we just put into a
bucket wash your face do this do that
and you're good you know what's dope so
um I was at Lake Arrowhead and then we
went on a little trail and we climbed
some [ __ ]
and we found this hammock out of nowhere
huh like they just built someone just
built like with the cables that should
look frightening his [ __ ] I did it looks
scary yeah but it was soul resident yeah
that's cool the world of us four guys
got in and didn't even break dude yeah
but whoever set that thing up they knew
what they were doing cuz I was like oh
my god it's gonna break its gonna break
but it did hammocks are so relaxing yeah
I wish I had a hand it was more like a
cave in what its relaxing until you try
to get out of that [ __ ] don't get out
they're not meant for you to get out you
know all your relaxation just disappears
in three seconds the first time i ever
got felt up was on hammock so good
memories good how do they fill you up he
probably wasn't even trying to um you
know what i do want to try though is
just get a sleeping bag and sleep
outdoors I never did that and I found
two little cave holes that I could crawl
into and then do it but I don't know
there might be a scorpion or open scary
that's what you need to take no
mosquitoes cuz that's not fun yeah
you've done it before right yeah and
you're like this and then you wake up
and there's like 20 mosquito bites in
your life [ __ ] yeah tell us about the
twins
yeah so eight FBI agents discovered a
[ __ ] ton of fireworks and a gas mask
they had like seven boxes of fireworks
and so one of the twins he was a former
teacher
please at a Harlem Prep and so he was
busted when agents went in with a search
warrant he was flushing marijuana down
the toilet they just wanted to party
this so they have fireworks marijuana
getting ready to [ __ ] Coachella yeah
here's the thing though because they
were arrested because they were accused
of offering students $50 an hour to
break apart fireworks and store the
powder that comes out of the firework in
compliance Mart and then they also got
hot texting each other
studying the Las Vegas shooter oh my god
oh they're deaf yes they're definitely
in love yes yeah brothers that are in
love they're in love for sure [ __ ]
each other all night yeah room must
stink well what they want to do what was
their gig where is their game plan
they're like overall plan yeah so then
they don't really get to that part
they're just trying to say here that
they were clearly trying to plan
something especially having that like
all that firework powder and yeah but
these are the twins here yeah they even
suck it big twins losers glasses are
[ __ ] boots yeah but their lawyer is
saying like well there is no bomb like
you guys don't have any hard proof first
of all [ __ ] that lawyer for even
defending them yeah but I always wish
that when bad guys get caught in real
life it's like in Scooby Doo where they
tell you what their plan was gonna be
like I was gonna build a firework that
would blow up the world and but if it
wasn't for you kids meddling kids
yeah like never gonna know straight up
even if they do go free you're gonna be
under watch constantly so good luck with
that yeah I wanted to make a bomb in
high school all right
have you heard of the Anarchist Cookbook
yeah I gave a glee well it's a very
interesting book about how to make bombs
and stuff like that should we really be
saying these things it's not hard to
find if they're really looking for its
no but it's like pushing cuz a lot of
people for this particular story they
were criticizing the media saying like
why are you telling people what they
were plant like how they were studying
but they weren't telling people
reporting the knee
no yeah for sure well it's been around
since the 60s and it's kind of open so
everyone knows about it if you know
about it
but um I figured out a way to use
piccolo Pete's you know from the stand
peel those out use the powder to make
snap old bottle bombs and that was
really fun because it would blow up and
the glass would fly everywhere oh oh no
just gasoline and a rag we could make
the car bombs yeah well I mean the
Molotov cocktails right yeah but I mean
I don't know where to get gasoline like
I could go to the fireworks stand and
then get like little streamers or
whatever and then construct that yeah
you mean oh they can as a kid like I
didn't know you could go and fill up a
little gallon or whatever yeah yeah so
that was really fun but then like I
never it was never in my mind to like do
any harm to people or whatever it was
just use mine to blow things up yeah I
have the capability so it's like cool I
could blow [ __ ] up but then you're like
the kid in Toy Story that blows up the
toilet yeah yes it or you want to like
you know like a lot of kids went to
Mexico and they got like a huge M 1000 s
and M 100's or whatever and it was the
funnest thing to like get you know
you're their sisters Barbie or whatever
and tie it to it and just just like
doing whatever what I know is that isn't
that normal TV I mean it
according to Toy Story I guess for boys
it is I don't know any of my girlfriends
that were like what she can we disrupt
what kind of [ __ ] up things I like
playing with the fire you were like that
in hallelujah
you said hasn't started no in elementary
but I think it got crazier and crazier
in high school like in elementary you
just want to see like matches and little
things blow it like maybe sixth grade or
fifth grade is when when you start
explore experimenting with different
hair sprays and then like the lighter
blow torches and [ __ ] yeah I never liked
exploding things but I did like
weaponry swords maces nunchucks brass
knuckles ninja stars is that I just like
that I didn't like anything that um I
didn't like blowing things up I don't
like burning things I didn't like
breaking anything I just like speed I
always wanted to be like a racer of some
sort like give me a bicycle and then I
added like remember that you would like
crush you can then add the can to it is
it that or the what does it play in cars
yeah
anything with speed like put me on a
hill and then like push me down
something I was like all about that well
for this start here though like cuz you
guys have expressed your thoughts on how
even if they get rid of guns like people
will always find different ways like
here's another example like they're
they're not using guns and their plot
but they're using explosives that are
purchased legally you could buy
fireworks and yet in some states it's
like so easy to get fireworks you just
have to put it together and you can blow
some stuff up you know what I don't see
here a lot and in LA it's like steep
driveways like that go into your garage
so like in like Sacramento these homes
have steep driveways so you drive up it
and then you park your car yeah cuz like
we would as a kid we would either get
our skateboards or a rollerblades and we
will go from that they go as fast as
possible and you just jet down and then
you just go as far as you that is fine
well I think la is not a very hilly area
but if you go more in like or the the
west side of it you'll steel start
saying because I see the driveways but
the driveways are flat and it goes into
the garage ours are like this is up and
then it's fine I would have been always
like that yeah it's pretty fun I would
have been about that for sure
yeah I like how being a kid you know you
just don't have no worries
you don't give all the joints your face
yeah yeah I'm worried like [ __ ] now
[Music]